c'était la fête ce jeudi 2 septembre
poissy la ville célébrer le retour de
ces traits athlètes médaillés aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo cet été en relais
mixte cassant beaugrand léonie périodes
d'orient coninx ont été accueillis par
des centaines de personnes devant la
mairie et se sont prêtées au
traditionnel jeu des autographes c'est
quoi ça fait ça fait plaisir que
que les gens soient là et qu'ils aient
apprécié et que les qui nous supportent
une émotion encore plus particulière
pour léonie perriot et cassante
beaugrand les deux sportives ont évolué
au sein des équipes de jeunes de poissy
triathlon avant d'être sur la scène
internationale moi ça fait ça fait un
long moment maintenant j'essaie vraiment
jeune quand j'étais au club donc ça fait
vraiment plaisir de le partager
justement ça fait très plaisir de
ramener la médaille à la ville c'est
vrai que bah c'est notre partenaire
phare donc ramener ça mon cas monsieur
le maire mais à tous les pisciacais ça
fait vraiment très plaisir cette
première médaille olympique française
dans cette discipline est également le
résultat de plusieurs années d'efforts
pour le club de poissy triathlon
structure fondée en 1983 qui compte
aujourd'hui près de 300 licenciés c'est
une journée de reconnaissance je crois
de du travail accompli depuis ces années
et puis d'une consécration suprême parce
que moins une médaille olympique ça ça
reste quand même quelque chose de très
très très particulière il a fallu aller
convaincre alors convaincre les
partenaires convaincre les élus
convaincre aussi toutes celles et ceux
qui n'y croyaient pas forcément et à
force de patience à force de conviction
mais ce club aujourd'hui l'un des
meilleurs clubs d'europe les trois
sportifs ont ensuite reçu des mains du
maire une autre médaille celle de la
ville de poissy et qu'elle est